hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast selecting the right resin
to achieve optimal results from
high-throughput batch to process scale
protein purification presented by Scott
Mayer and Aaron McBride both scientists
three protein cell and cell analysis
life sciences solutions group Thermo
Fisher Scientific we are excited to
bring you this educational webcast
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
get Co part of thermo Fisher Scientific
I'm julissa merav lab routes and I'll be
your moderator for today's event before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window they type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please note that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the Wulin window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem now please
join me in welcoming Scott Meyer and
Erin McBride I will now turn the
presentation over to them thanks for the
introduction
so I named Scott Meyer and today my
colleague Aaron McBride and I will be
presenting a talk on selecting the right
resin to achieve optimal results from
high-throughput batch to process scale
protein purification there's an
increasing focus on protein research
whether it be for structure function
studies understanding interactions of a
protein of interest or the development
of a potential bio therapeutic this
research requires efficient and
effective isolation of pure protein at a
variety of scales chrome attack
you resin performance requirements can
vary depending on protein
characteristics and scale producing a
quality protein while reducing costs and
time without compromising performance
can be a challenge
Thermo Fisher Scientific is committed to
providing flexible high performance
beads and resins for high throughput
purification and scaleable purification
capabilities here's some of the unique
purification challenges researchers
might encounter on a daily basis that
can hamper productivity researchers
working in academia or industry doing
small-scale purification at the
milligram level may be screening
different conditions for optimal
purification of their protein or
proteins of interest they face the
challenge of achieving optimal yield and
purity with minimal purification steps
and high-throughput production
scientists purifying protein at the gram
level pilot-scale
are typically developing a protein for
commercial purpose and are tasked with
optimizing a purification process at the
gram scale we face the challenge of
scaling up and achieving high yield and
purity all at a reasonable cost a
process scientists purifying kilograms
of protein has a constant focus on
efficiency they're faced with the
challenge of improving productivity and
reducing costs of protein purification
while still meeting regulatory needs
these challenges require simplifying the
process and reducing costs choosing the
right protein purification resin will
help make the process effective and
efficient so there's different base
supports for chromatography and protein
purification and each one is catered to
a specific application this table shown
here provides guidance on our
definitions of protein purification
scales and through and throughput needs
so for customers requiring batch
purification at all throughputs
we recommend magnetic agarose the sports
ideal for automated scouting of
conditions for protein purification for
batch the pilot-scale we might recommend
our SuperFlow resins which can be used
either in a drip or spin column format
and F PLC this resin is very versatile
and is useful for researchers requiring
larger amounts of protein for structural
studies and is also useful for an
intermediate scale protein production at
the pilot scale for batch the process
scale we recommend are porous resin this
base support is geared specifically for
F plc and all flow rates and can
significantly improve processing speed
of bulk production I've highlighted the
different base beads we have available
and what applications they're
recommended for now I'll discuss some of
the functionalities available on these
supports for purifying proteins we'll be
focusing specifically on affinity
chromatography as a tool for protein
purification affinity chromatography
provides a straightforward positive
selection strategy for protein
purification purification is often as
simple as binding washing and loop a
variety of immobilized ligands are
available to provide a high fold pyrrha
fication with ease of use in mind
significantly reducing process
optimization and variability seeing with
other chromatography methods such as ion
exchange or hydrophobic interaction
depending on the immobilized affinity
likened a high level of purity and yield
can be attained in a single column
purification a strategy is often
implemented for the purification of
recombinant proteins using a tag based
capture and also for the purification of
full-length antibody using immobilized
antibody binding proteins we'll be
showcasing purification supports for tag
base to finish
capture and antibody purification in
this presentation so in the first half
of this presentation I'll be focusing on
affinity purification of recombinant
expressed proteins sharing data on our
magnetic agarose beads and our super
fluorescence some common affinity
purification strategies include
immobilized metal affinity
chromatography or imac for binding poly
histidine tags and mobilized Gouda
theone or gsh for binding GST fusion
proteins poly histidine tag protein
capture utilizes immobilized
tetradentate metal key leaders charged
with nickel cobalt this ligand will bind
proteins tagged with multiple histidines
fused at the N or C terminus of the
protein nickel coordinated with nitro
Chola as try acetic acid MTA as a higher
binding capacity while cobalt is more
selective resulting in higher purity
glutathione is a tripeptide ligand that
binds GST a twenty six killa dalton and
terminal fusion as a substrate GST folds
quickly to help with solubility of your
target protein and it can even improve
expression of some our Gurkha Express
recombinant proteins glutathione is very
specific specific to GST resulting in
high purity Alouettes
this table shows all the supports for
poly histidine tag to GST fusion
recombinant protein purification
available from thermo Fisher Scientific
and the applications they are
recommended for I will be highlighting
advantages of magnetic agarose beads for
high throughput batch purifications and
super fluorescents for larger scale
purifications Pierce magnetic agarose
beads are highly cross-linked providing
a robust support with low nonspecific
binding and a larger surface area than
other polymer based magnetic beads for a
higher binding capacity the beads which
are 10 to 40 microns in size are easier
to handle compared to other larger
magnetic agarose beads and have a slower
settling rate which helps keeps the
beads suspended while batch binding your
protein of interest the beads are
embedded with magnetite resulting in
fast collection and strong magnetic
attraction so the graph on the right
shows that smaller magnetic beads have
more beads left in the supernatant after
collection for 10 to 60 seconds while
the Pierce magnetic agarose beads have
very little left in the supernatant
compared to a blank without any beads
even after a short collection time of 10
seconds and the Pierce magnetic agarose
beads are available with nickel nta and
glutathione ligands for recombinant
tagged affinity protein purification
protein yields an important aspect for
all skills of protein purification and
not just high-throughput batch so we
looked at the capacities and yields of
two different proteins either his tagged
or GST fusion proteins expressed in
e.coli cultures and lysed with beber
complete and then purified following
recommended protocols for a variety of
actually available magnetic agarose
beads for both his tagged and GST fusion
expressed proteins thermo scientific
Pierce magnetic agarose beads resulted
in the highest yield increased recovery
with Pierce magnetic agarose beads
reduces the cost per make of protein
purified and it also allows for smaller
volume expressions and you'd still
obtain the same amount of protein you
would get when purifying with other
magnetic agarose beads at higher
expression volumes thus freeing up more
space on shaker platforms additionally
the yields obtained at this scale with
Pierce magnetic agarose beads could
enable studies requiring higher amounts
of protein such as functional activity
measurements and even some structural
analysis the highly homogeneous product
is also important for protein
purification increased capture of target
protein and low nonspecific binding is
ideal for highly homogeneous
purifications optimizing the amount of
target protein to beat volume ratio will
help to reduce contamination from other
proteins his tag puree lightened ligase
and GST green Rinella were purified with
various magnetic bead supports following
manufacturer's protocol and equal
amounts of eluded protein were separated
by SDS page and assess for purity the
Pierce nickel nta magnetic agarose beads
resulted in greater than 90% pure
protein for his tag purification and
glutathione magnetic agarose beads
resulted in greater than 95 percent
purity for GST fusion proteins
magnetic beads have traditionally been
thought of having lower binding capacity
than traditional agarose magnetic
agarose provides a similar functional
ligand density as traditional agarose
resins additionally since magnetic
agarose beads have a smaller diameter
than traditional agarose residents you
get a higher cumulative binding surface
which is advantageous for the smaller
microliter
resin volume skills we purified a
variety of his tagged and GST fusion
proteins with the same volume of
magnetic agarose beads and agarose
resident for the hist AG purification
thermo scientific Pierce nickel nta
magnetic agarose beads Frank comparably
to an agarose resin in regards to yield
whereas with the magnetic agarose beads
you actually outperform glutathione
agarose present at this scale possibly
due to increased surface area and better
capture at low protein concentrations
automation is essential as sample
numbers and throughput increases
automating magnetic agarose speed
protein purification is a
straightforward procedure using the
thermo scientific kingfisher magnetic
bead processor you can see that time
required for each affinity purification
step is similar for automated magnetic
agarose and manual agarose based
purifications however with the manual
process using traditional agarose you
have a lot more handling steps whereas
automation allows the users to do other
tasks while purification runs thermo
scientific magnetic agarose beads are
compatible with both manual and
automated protocols for manual methods
up to 16 samples can be purified in a
little over an hour as mentioned on the
last slide the higher throughput is
simplified with use of the kingfishers
flex purification system
which can process 96 samples at a time
in less than 90 minutes
Pierce magnetic agarose beads performed
similarly in manual or automated methods
hiss tagged and GST fusion protein
purifications had similar yields for
manual purifications or automated
purifications and less than 5% variance
between triplicate purifications on the
kingfishers platform here are
applications in which nickel nta or
ludus I own magnetic agarose beads have
been used to optimize protein
purification at the high throughput
screening scale so not all proteins are
stabled soluble and buffers used during
purification finding conditions in which
a protein retains its native structure
or does not precipitate out of solution
can be arduous an additive screen can be
done at small scale to flank tolerable
conditions for your protein of interest
using standard purification purification
conditions hist egg biotin ligase
precipitated an Aleutian buffer after
about 10 minutes of storage conditions
were scouted to approve stability and
solubility of this protein using nickel
nta magnetic agarose beads addition of
20% glycerol to The Binding wash and
Aleutian buffers significantly improved
yields and solubility of his tagged
biotin ligase
accessibility of the tag for
purification can also be screened with
magnetic agarose beads placement of the
tag in quaternary structure influences
binding of target protein to the
affinity resin confirming the correct
placement of affinity tags with magnetic
agarose beads before doing larger scale
purifications helps to prevent loss of
time and money Cho abt expressed
c-terminal hissed at proteins were
purified following manual protocol with
Pierce nickel nta magnetic agarose beads
load flow through first wash and Holly
wet fractions were evaluated by Western
blot using an anti his 5 antibody p53
which forms a tetra maracle 53 kill
adult and proteins had poor binding
probably due to low accessibility of the
hist AG at the c-terminus GST fusions
were also screened for tag accessibility
with protein a/g fusion showing poor
binding four of the six constructs
screened would be ready to scale-up
however the p53 and protein a/g
constructs would require further
optimization before scaling up overall
Pierce magnetic agarose beads have
significant benefits for high-throughput
batch affinity purification of
recombinant tag proteins including high
binding capacity and automation
capabilities this support is extremely
versatile and can be used to rapidly and
efficiently evaluate additive screening
wash conditions tag accessibility
protein engineering and protein protein
interactions for his tag or GST fusion
recombinant protein now to talk about
selecting resins for higher scale
recombinant protein purification scaling
up to the gram level pilot scale
requires a resin which can tolerate high
flow rates and have high specificity
to decrease run times and chromatic
chromatic graphy steps required
SuperFlow resins are highly cross-linked
and can tolerate up to 0.6 mega Pascal
back pressure and linear flow rates up
to 1200 centimeters per hour the graph
on the right shows that super flow six
residents tolerate flow rate
significantly higher than other agarose
residents before the residents start to
compress the surface of the super flow
six particle helps to provide high
binding capacity necessary for the scale
and available residents include
immobilized nickel nta and cobalt super
flow for imac and immobilized
glutathione for GST fusion purifications
super flow six resins are ideal for
column based affinity purification the
resin can be used in batch bind format
important to a gravity flow column or
pre packed into an F plc column for
larger volume purifications
for F plc purifications the protein is
loaded onto the column under flow and
the binding is dynamic binding will be
dependent on the amount of residence
each time the protein gets to bind to
the resin this residency time is
inversely related to the flow rate
dynamic binding capacities for his pure
nickel nta super flow his pure cobalt
super flow and glutathione super flow
are shown here the resins all have high
binding capacities bank
Basti will be protein specific
determining your binding capacity can be
useful for further process improvement
identifying the flow rate at what you
see in an inflection point in the
binding capacity is a good starting
point for optimal flow rate and yield in
your purification process reusing
columns packed with super flow resins is
possible generating additional cost
savings nickel nta super flow resident
tolerate sanitization and clean in place
with 0.5 molar sodium hydroxide
for a total of 26 runs without
significant loss of performance cobalt
SuperFlow does not tolerate stringent
clean in places but typically only
requires a low pH must buffer to clean
in place no decrease in protein yield
purity or increase in back pressures
were observed after 25 cycles
glutathione super flow can also be
reused at least 25 times with a simple
guanidine HCl and ethanol clean in place
with no significant loss in yield or
purity additionally with the iMac
residents very low metal leaching was
observed in the Aleutians determined by
icp-ms this is important since leached
nickel or cobalt can lead to damage a
protein so here's a typical pilot-scale
run for purification of a histidine
pilot-scale purifications
were conducted on 100 grams of e.coli
biomass overexpressing his tag GFP with
columns packed with either 200 mils of
nickel nta SuperFlow or cobalt SuperFlow
one liter of total lysate was passed
over the column at a flow rate of 20
mils per minute and next washed the base
line with either buffer containing 30
milli molar a minute solve for nickel
nta or 15 milli molar and that's all for
cobalt finally protein was eluded with
300 milli molar a minute solve for the
nickel nta column and 150 milli molar
minutes all for the cobalt column in
fractions containing purified 6 excess
gfp were pooled and protein
concentration was measured using protein
660 si both purification runs were
completed in under three hours and for
this particular purification greater
than 4 grams of protein was purified
with both nickel nta and kupo cobalt
SuperFlow however the cobalt SuperFlow
resulted in greater purity
SuperFlow resins provide substantial
benefits who batched the pilot-scale
purification for F PLC including high
dynamic binding capacity high flow rates
used in large-scale F PLC applications
super flow resins are available with
nickel nta cobalt ore glutathione
ligands to enhance yield or purity the
residents have low liken leaching and
can be reused at least 25 times in
summary our portfolio of recombinant
protein purification tools provide the
following benefits key ligands are
available to meet typical purification
needs our resins and beads are
economically priced and perform well in
regards to binding capacity and purity
and we have a variety of supports to
accommodate all scales allowing the user
to choose the right support to optimize
the recombinant protein purification so
I'll turn things over to my colleague
Erin McBride who will be just discussing
antibody purification here
thanks for the introduction Scot affinis
resins as Scott mentioned can be broken
down several categories such as
tag-based purifications immobilize
antibodies and of course antibody
purifications for the second half of the
talk I will go over some of the
chromatography resins in our portfolio
they'll make an abiding workflows easier
and much more efficient specifically
I'll talk about our Pierce magnetic iris
beads and our thermo Fisher Scientific
corals mad capture select roses first
we'll talk about the multiple offending
I guess used for the purification of
antibodies the classic Alliance for
antibody purification are either protein
a or protein cheap 13 a is using the
majority of Anna my dear efficacious do
this better chemical tolerance which is
useful when cleaning and reuse and resin
and antibodies that can be eluted are
milder conditions protein a binds the
ch2ch3 interface but can also bind the
bh3 variable region allowing it to bind
some fats the disadvantage of protein is
that it does not bite igg3 and it does
not bind all fats protein g in contrast
binds at the ch2ch3 interface but also
binds at the CH one allowing to bind all
fats in addition protein g binds igg3
and has poor binding to other IgG
subtypes such as IgA and IgM the
disadvantage to using protein G is that
does have lower chemical compatibility
and typically harsher conditions are
needed to elute well the majority of the
purification are binding a human or
humanized IgG antibody there's also a
significant amount of purifications I
deal with non-human animals the
specificity of protein a and protein g
to non-human antibodies can be very
great very greatly and care should be
taken when choosing lie against so for a
non-human antibody in most cases they
are complementary in that if protein a
does not bind or binds weakly so one
species protein G will bind strong to
that species four labs are doing a
purification on a wide range of
antibodies
Keiji offers a lot an all-in-one
solution protein a/g is a chimeric
protein that combines the five ana by
binding sites approaching a and the two
antibody binding sites of protein chi
for an all-in-one resin allowing for an
for it to handle all purification
options within our antibody purification
portfolio we have protein a protein g
and protein a/g resins on a wide variety
of base of course through the remainder
of the discussion will be focus on two
of those base supports magnetic agarose
for high-throughput batch applications
and porous for column chromatography
applications that range from milligram
to kilogram quantities as Scott
mentioned previously Pierce magnetic
agarose beads are highly cross-linked
ten to 40 micron agarose beat that has
been embedded with magnetic we have then
immobilized protein a/g to the bead
which creates an easy handling robust
magnetic particle that has broad idg
specificity we now look at how the
Pierce magnetic Argos works in some
purification studies this data is
showing that the binding of capacity of
13 AG magnetic agarose beads compared to
both tes protein a and protein g mag
Sepphoris resins you can see from the
graph on the left the Pierce protein a/g
magnetic are gross B's has higher IgG
binding capacity than both cheeese mag
sephorus protein a and protein g
residents across a wide variety of
isotypes when using a purified IgG in
many cases though purification from a
complex sample vastly different from
that of a purified IgG
to look at how the resins compare we
used using a complex sample we prepared
a purification of IgG from syrup in both
human and mouth ceará the protein a/g
magnetic agarose beads had equivalent or
higher capacity while also having a
purity that has higher or equal to the
competitor Bresson however one aspect of
working with magnetic resonance
that truly makes it efficient as the
magnetics of course can be automated
here we are showing a purification of a
human IgG though it's expressed in our X
P Cho system in this experiment we were
looking to identify how reproducible is
a purification on an automated system
here for this we purified perform the
purification on the kingfishers guro
system in 12 replicates on the left you
can see a reducing and non reducing
sds-page looking at the purity of the
human IgG that was purified the purity
on all 12 samples linear example the
results on the right show the total
yield from each purification and as you
can see with a high degree of
reproducibility in summary our Peirce
1380 magnetic agarose resin is a high
capacity and can has a high purity IgG
resin that allows for easy automation
and also has a broad IgG specificity to
academe most idg up isotypes next we
will discuss resins that are suitable
for column chromatography as with all
the resins discussed in this talk is the
ligand a resin combination that dictates
the efficacy of your total purification
and the next resin is no exception
Thermo Fisher Scientific course
chromatography bead offers this high
efficient for concur McCarthy and
provides a number of highly advantageous
performance features the first is that
it's made of polystyrene developments so
the bead ins are rigid and
incompressible this allows them to
easily be handled and the beads have
very robust physical and chemical
stability in addition the rigidity
allows for operation at very high linear
flow rates second natural second
attribute is the fact that they have
very large pore structure which allows
for convective flow through the beat
this large pore structure allows the
Beno chair increasing the surface area
and resulting in higher capacity also
due to the large through pores the beads
have improved mass transfer capability
allowing for more efficient eat so you
can maintain higher capacity and higher
resolution independent of the operating
slow rate this leads to higher fishing
at increased linear flow rates and
improves process productivity lastly the
beads have an average particle size of
50 microns most residents have an
average particle size of 90 to 100
microns have a particle size that
roughly half the size of most other
resins allow for superior resolution in
addition pores is a fully scalable and
process excellent and possesses
excellent pressure flow properties with
pores performance is independent of both
the scale and the flow rate of your
operation which means the ideal
purification resin but how does it
compare to typical agarose beads
typically with conventional media the
pores are much smaller so diffusion in
and out of the small pores controls
performance and conventional
chromatography diffusion is regulated by
residence time the longer residence time
the deeper the molecule can penetrate
the resin and the higher binding
capacity and better mass transfer you
acquire residence time however is
inversely proportional Floria thus the
practical consequence is that when
linear velocity increases through the
column capacity and resolution decline
of rapidly thus you cannot speed up the
process by increasing flow rate as it is
controlled by the size concentration
temperature and the KD for your specific
molecule porous chromatography resins
offer a difference than traditional
chromatography softgels and that Poros
the bead is transected by a wider
through pores which unlocks the bead
interior and allows convective flow plus
much shorter and shallower diffusional
course since diffusional distances are
reduced mass transfer has improved and
the practical consequence is that linear
velocity increases through the column
capacity and resolution originally
affected these effects are more easily
seen and looking breakthrough curves
this slide shows customer generated data
that illustrates how breakthrough curves
can be inflated by flow rates on both
the porous beat and
Rose beat the y-axis is the amount of
IgG in the flow through which is C over
the amount of hydrogen the load which is
c0 with the ratio of 1 equals nothing
and binding it all by sites are taken
the faster the transition from 0 to 1
the more efficient the colonists if we
look at the far right light far right
line in both graphs which is 50 families
per hour we see that the perfusion media
C over C 0 is above 0.9 or 90% fairly
quickly after breakthrough while Argos
barely over 60% at the same volume if we
look at the far left line in both graph
which is 700 cycles per hour we see two
things one is the shape of the curve is
concave self convex which indicates poor
binding while the porous material stays
convexed the other item to notice is
that the distance between the slowest
flow rate the far right and the fastest
flow rate the far left there's clearly a
large range in the Argos material
indicating a larger change dynamic
binding capacity over the range of flow
rates while the difference between the
fastest and the slower rates for the
poorest Rosa has a significantly smaller
change and thus binding capacity is
minimally impacted by flow rate this
demonstrates the poorest binding
capacity is independent of Fleury this
is further illustrated with all of our
mad capture select resins mad capture
select resins are all the plastic ax
antibody binding glycans protein a
protein g and protein a/g on the poor
speed all the mad captures liquor resins
around a 50 micron bead for the optimal
performance since they are on the poro
speed they maintain high binding
capacity across a large range of flow
rates up to 5,000 signage per hour and
also have robust physical stability and
low back brush making them an excellent
choice for scaling up the process scale
the graph on the right is shown the
dynamic binding capacity of Poros mat
capture a select versus map select over
a variety of flurries as limit to the
last slide the binding capacity for map
select starts to drop off after 300
sandwich Brower while mad capture a slit
maintains the binding capacity across a
wide range of flow rates this is also
true for a newly developed mat capture
protein g and AG select resins porous
mad captured g select a setting the new
standard for protein gene resins the top
graph shows dynamic binding capacity
using human IgG for the new Poros mad
capture G select as compared to the
leading protein G resident in the market
protein G sepharose or phase low and our
historic protein g + agarose resins mad
capture g select maintains close to
double the binding capacity when
compared to protein g sepharose for fast
flow and maintains binding capacity over
a wide range of flow rates the loyal
Varsho chromatograms using either mad
captured g select or protein g sepharose
fat flow these resins were loaded with
either go to human serum they contain
approximately 12 mix of IgG the graph in
the lower left you can see that mad
captured G select has a large Aleutian
profile indicating a higher binding
capacity then that of protein g
cephalosporin fast low on the right you
can see the mad capture G so it has a
similar binding capacity to protein G
sepharose for fast low but has more
efficient mass transfer which allows for
the protein to be eluded in smaller
volumes there's similar story format
capture AG select mat capture a CG
select maintains fivefold higher
capacity for human IgG over our older AG
resum
Pierce protein AG plus and multiple
floor it's similar to protein G
residence we loaded mad captured G
select and Pierce protein a/g
agarose resins with the goat serum that
contains approximately 12 means of IgG
we see that mat capture G select
maintains higher binding capacity and
also has better mass transfer in summary
to the Poros unique beet structure the
post mad captures luck residents love
for high binding capacity and multiple
flow rates with minimal change due to
the reduction of residence time also do
the improve mass transfer and convective
flow the Rezo allows for smaller
Ellucian
which minimizes downstream
purification steps as illustrated in our
previous slides are affinity resins
offer unique ligands that can meet the
demands of even the most challenging
protein purification the main function
of the capture step in a process
concentrate the target protein and
purify as much as possible high formed
chromatography resins like Poros can
offer benefits and clear high dynamic
binding across a wide range of
conditions
excellent clean ability and superior
resolution a lot for smaller pool lines
next we will present a case study
showing how porous can decrease the
overall time to purify a product and how
this can lead to lower cost of goods
both very important as process processes
are scaled and move through the
development by increasing the throughput
process flexibility and process
performance the cost associated with
purification can be decreased and more
productive processes can be realized
decreasing the cost of redevelopment at
a later stage that can further speed the
overall time market I will now present
be presenting a case study from one of
our customers that switch to our Poros
mat capture a select resin from GE
recombinant a fast flow the customers
commercial supply of primary and
secondary antibodies to researchers IVD
and Eliza manufacturers they were using
a conventional soft gel protein a resin
and they wanted to compare to Poros mat
capture a select in this case study the
company was purify antibodies from mouse
societies and historically have used the
GE recombinant protein hey that's law
for all their clarifications the
challenge was to reduce processing time
in order to decrease to increase
throughput
and move to a resin that was less
expensive the help with overall cogs
they went ahead minimal changes the
process and they did not want to have to
change buffers or ads at any subsequent
purification steps for their application
only a single purification was needed
their goals were to increase process
time by at least 25 percent and also
have the resin that was at least 25
percent lowering costs this would allow
them to reduce the overall cause by
grading 30
such in addition processing time and
cost of the resin they were looking at
total yield and abide purity as well as
activity the left chromatogram shows two
identical purifications of mouse idg
from mao societies using either Poros
mad capture a select or recombinant
protein a Cerro fast flow the red line
is the pearls mad capture a select well
the blue line is the recombinant protein
ATF rose for fast flow you notice that
the elution volume format capture a
sledge is about 30% smaller than that of
the recombinant protein a it maintains
similar yield they analyze purity by SDS
page and they did not see any difference
in purity between anti-vice purified i'm
porous mad capture a select and
recombinant protein ASA froze vessel
lastly they test the activity which was
not shown here but they did not detect
any difference now between the Hana
bodies that are purified I'll achieve
different resins they proceed to
increase the counts our production scale
and try to exploit horses properties by
increasing flurries to reduce the
processing time on the left you can see
their typical productions Gale protocol
when they use the poorest to its fullest
vanish they were able to achieve
processing times on the right and the
result is a reduction of processed time
of approximately 82 percent and add a
reduction to cost the resin by greater
than 30 percent using the faster time
they did not notice the difference in
the activity yield or purity from their
overall small screen testing so they are
able to achieve the same product and
reduce processing it by time by fivefold
this was a huge advantage to them and
they were able to significantly increase
throughput for their lab similar results
could be seen on bioprocess scale while
we don't have a case study we have model
model clarification use mat capture a
select and map select on the bioprocess
scale in this model the total feed stock
would be 10,000 liters at a feed at a
concentration of five makes per mil and
it on a three hundred and eight liter
column
if we look at three different flow rates
200 400 600 centimeters per hour binding
capacity of the resin at those flow
rates number of cycles needed to purify
the entire feedstock based on the
fluorescent capacity and cumulative
process time we see that at 200
centimeters per hour the flow rates are
about equal and the processing there
would be no reduction in the process if
you increase the flourish to 400
centimeters per hour and compared to the
time of the 200 centimeters per hour
purification there will be a reduction
in time for both
however the porous mat temperature a
select would have a greater time saving
because there would have to be an extra
purification performed using matte
capture a select due to their loss of
binding capacity and the extra
purification being needed at 600
centimeters per hour
pause map capture eh liquid still be a
purify the entire feed site and for
purification and as such the time
reduction is significantly greater if we
model a similar scenario where we
compared map select map select share and
map capture a select
Lucey significant cost savings we looked
at similar flow rates to those used in
the previous model 200 400 600 samri's
per hour flow rates number of cycles
required buffer costs process labor
costs resin costs and total cost per
batch one thing you noticed immediately
is that the majority of the cost per
batch is the resin cost the process
labor cost and buffer cost is
significantly lower there would be a
cost savings of approximately 30% over
GE map select media and 50% over the GES
map select share using porous mad
capture a select and summary regardless
of the scale there is a significant
performance advantage and cost savings
advantage when switching to the porous
mat capture a select resins
our company has an established
reputation for tools and resources for
the high performance Effendi
purification of proteins our broad
portfolio of products manufacturing at
state of art facilities include a wide
range of base of horse and lions at
every scale in addition we offer global
support and technical expertise for all
of our purification products if you'd
like to know more information about any
of our products for your protein
research feel free to take a look at our
protein research tool on our website
thermo fisher comm forward slash protein
purification tool this talk to
demonstrate how thermo Fisher can
provide you with the resins needed to
enhance your purification workflow and
with that take any questions
thank you Scott and Aaron for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button on the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
it as many questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
it's for Scott Scott Ken magnetic
agarose beads be used for immuno
precipitation or Co IP experiments
yeah so we've we've used magnetic
agarose for IP and kolecki experiments
the nickel nta and glutathione magnetic
agarose beads also work for pull-down
experiments or bait prey evaluations of
looking at binding partners since the
beads have a lot higher binding capacity
than other magnetic agarose or other
magnetic beads you would want to use
lower volumes typically we're using like
10 to 20 microliters of bead slurry but
you know and again since since the beads
have a lot higher binding capacity
they're more geared for high-throughput
low scale purification great thank you
the next question is for Aaron you've
talked about using Poros impact
chromatography columns for an LC can
Poros be used in gravity flow or spin
column thanks for that question so
really they can be used in spin columns
you just don't get all the benefits that
go along with the porous chromatography
resins gravity flow however they
significant slow down the flow rates due
to their bead structure and the small
particle size so it's really not
recommended for gravity chromatography
okay great the next question is what's
the best purification product for the XP
ciao and XP two nine three systems and
I'm not sure which of you would be best
to answer that so we've we've seen that
for his tag purification of proteins
secreted into xB 293 or XP Cho media
that there is some interference with the
purification performance of our nickel
nta resins you can overcome that by dial
izing or buffer exchanging the the media
into recommended binding buffers for
antibody purifications the antibody
secreting secreted into the media is
directly compatible with our magnetic
protein a/g beads shown earlier and it
should also be compatible directly with
any of our protein a/g or AG supports
which support to use is probably
dependent on the volume and expression
level of your system
thank you Scott the next question would
be for Aaron what type of column do you
recommend for Poros map capture select
resin do I need a high pressure column
for porous so do the beach structure
again for the Poros it's rigid and
compressible so you can use high
pressure columns however you can use
this typical stainless steel or glass
column and that would be perfectly
sufficient part of the structure are
porous itself allows it to generate low
back pressure so even though that it's a
smaller particle feed you don't
necessarily get a huge increase in back
pressure I do typically would see in
smaller beads thank you so much for that
answer and we'll wrap up with one more
question for Scott you had a slide
showing magnetic agarose had high-yield
higher yields compared to non-magnetic
agarose for in I NT a included Scion
small-scale purifications can you
elaborate on why the magnetic agarose
beads have better recovery I could
postulate alright I mean I don't know
exactly for sure but since the magnetic
agarose bead has a smaller diameter it's
10 to 40 microns in size compared to
agarose which is anywhere from 50 to 150
microns you have more beads in the same
volume of of you know so like a 100
micro litre settled volume of magnetic
agarose is going to have more beads than
100 microliters settle settled volume of
traditional agarose
so you know potentially you'd have a
higher cumulative surface for your
target to bind to the the nice thing
about magnetic agarose and traditional
agarose presents they they have similar
ligand densities so you get similar
affinity or avidity with with both beads
just we have noticed especially with
with the glutathione when you have lower
scale expressions on like the hundreds
of microgram scale that for whatever
reason the the magnetic agarose kudasai
ohm binds to GST fusions better than the
larger traditional agarose speed
thank you
I'd like to once again thank Scott and
Aaron for their presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots and Ditko
part of thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible additional questions will be
answered and published on Thermo Fisher
Scientific sweb site you will receive an
email notification when answers are
available before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through April 2018 you will receive an
email from Lavery's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon
goodbye